So Donald Trump's taxes are back in the news
and have actually been subpoenaed by the Manhattan
District Attorney State Prosecutors in Manhattan
have subpoenaed Donald Trump's accounting
firm demanding eight years of both Trump's
personal and business tax returns.
Now, the first question we might ask is district
attorney, if a district attorney is issuing
a subpoena for Donald Trump's tax returns,
is this related to some kind of investigation?
And the answer is that yes, it turns out that
at the end of August, a criminal investigation
was opened up into those hush money payments
made by Donald Trump to mistresses.
And I know many of us are completely fatigued
and sick of this hush money thing by now.
Um, and I'll sort of address that in a second.
These are the payments that were made.
The payments were made in a, in a literal
sense by Trump's now in prison, personal attorney
Michael Cohen.
But of course they were made in service to
Donald Trump and Donald Trump as far as we
know, reimburse those payments to Michael
Cohen.
So that's the answer to question one.
It's part of that invent a new criminal investigation.
Question two is what's the full scope of this
Manhattan district attorney probe?
Is it related only to the 2016 hush money
payments or is there some broader campaign
finance or other investigation that this is
part of?
We don't know the answer to that.
We know that one legal question about the
hush money, uh, particularly the payment made
to stormy Daniels is did Donald Trump's business
call that illegal expense in their accounting,
which would be number one, hilarious.
And number two potentially illegal and a felony
if it was done to conceal some other crime
like tax evasion or bank fraud or in the service
of some additional crime.
So we'll figure that out.
Maybe someday.
But let's get more to what matters here and
what doesn't matter.
I understand we are mostly sick of this entire
hush money payment thing.
The hush money payments themselves as a way
to punish Donald Trump or make him suffer
consequences for the things that he did.
I believe that that ship has sailed.
We can, as a practical matter, vote Donald
Trump out way faster than the hush money payment
investigation could even potentially remove
him from office.
It just not gonna happen.
We shouldn't even be thinking about that.
Then we get to the content of the tax returns
themselves.
That's actually what we're interested in.
Now, that being said, this is a district attorney
subpoena for an investigation if they get
the tax returns, meaning if the grand jury
gets those tax returns, they would not even
go public unless they're leaked.
Of course, unless they end up becoming evidence
at a trial.
That is also extremely unlikely to happen.
So I don't really see this as something to
be optimistic about in terms of the material
getting to us for our review, but it's yet
another thing that could trigger Donald Trump.
First of all.
Secondly, every time that we do hear anything
related to the content of Donald Trump's taxes,
it's been something that makes him look terrible,
so there is still the potential here that
if any of this is released in any way leaked
or otherwise, it's going to contain extremely
damaging information about Donald Trump.
Remember that when the summaries of Donald
Trump's tax returns got out, we learned that
he lost just like insane amounts of money
and they put out his attorney or someone put
out a statement saying, oh, this is all calculated.
You know, he's gaming the system and this
is all because he's such a great businessman.
People who were not working for Trump, who
know about tax law and accounting looked at
it and said, no, no, no.
This is just the guys really losing a lot,
a lot of money, or he lost a lot of money
in that time.
It would not be for the tax benefits.
We also learned from other tax disclosures
of Trump that we got awhile ago that Donald
Trump's dad had financed a lot of Donald Trump's
failures, that we call that rich dad bails
me out.
Just like the height of privilege for someone
claiming to be a self made man.
So this could be interesting if something
like that comes out.
It could be interesting in that even just
fighting, it could become a big story and
expensive Donald Trump, which would be just
delightful.
But as far as getting rid of Trump, as far
as exposing criminality, the strategy remains
the same one that it's been for more than
a year, vote Trump out in November of 2020
he'll be gone when a new president is inaugurated
in January of 2021 and it will be far, far
more efficient than any of these ideas related
to tax returns or the 25th amendment or impeachment.
I know the fans of each of those individually
will say no, those are great ideas, David,
and they may well be, but they're not going
to get Trump out any faster than just voting
him out in November.
If you disagree with me, let me know.